Ah ah ah
[music] Then my
friend-like ability just happened
[music]
voodoo Oh my God
, this guy is a low-spedator of acrobatics
Which troupe did you belong to
?
I'm going to talk to you Prishgameter-san.
You should practice Harakiri more than the limit.You're practicing Harakiri,
aren't
you
?
My hands are
out.I'm just concentrating on my feet, so I'm sorry.If you call me by the
name of Genji, I can go with my father, but it's seven times different.What are
you looking at?
I thought about it, but told me Magura is
good, Percy, of course, fibrillation and appearance, so it's not a two-line separation, I'm going to sell fonts.
Rah Horror It's
to get Sugimoto out of the park
.  I was taken